[Music]
since World of Warcraft was released in
2004 the games best players have raced
to be the first to complete its raids a
ray is like a massive dungeon with
complex bosses to defeat and in the old
days raids could get as big as 40
players nowadays they range anywhere
from 10 to 30 but the hardest raid
difficulty in the game right now mythic
requires exactly 20 players and they all
need to be playing at an incredible
level if they want to overcome its
challenges and in 2018 one of the game's
most important guilds took the world
first race to its biggest stage yet
twitch so rating isn't anything new it's
been a part of WoW since the game came
out and with every raid the game's story
gets pushed further there must always be
and since release the game's best skill
to have written a story of their own as
they tested himself against the hardest
raid content the Wow had to offer
[Applause]
[Music]
towards the end of the original World of
Warcraft before the first expansion came
out the competition to clear new rage
became more formalized and the race to
complete the original max ramus raid was
a frequent topic of conversation the
world first race became an informal but
extremely competitive undertaking the
games developer who lizard entertainment
seemed fascinated by the cutting edge
rating guilds even hosting some custom
head-to-head rating at Blizzcon right
now
[Applause]
but Blizzard never directly supported
the world-first race as evidenced by the
continued inequality between North
American and European guilds the server
reset times favor na giving them a
24-hour head start the world first race
is something that is obviously it's
intriguing as I was amazing seeing the
very very best Raiders in the world
practice their craft but we're building
our raids to present an epic experience
to tell a story to you know create
engaging and immersive battles for
millions of players and we're always
going to prioritize the depth of that
experience over the nuances of the race
the WoW community always look to the
reigning scene whenever a new rain tea
released but the race itself was usually
a little more than screenshots showing
that bosses had been defeated there was
no way to watch it live if you were a
fan you have to wait patiently to
eventually see the kill video enter
method the guild began to contend with
some of the game's top guild during the
Cataclysm expansion but broke through
with their first world first clear
during this up-and-down and since that
time method is a master most world first
of any guilt out of the 14 rage released
between mists of pandaria and today
method has claimed the world first on
tanada and they did it with a 24 hour
disadvantage compares in north america
but before old dear
the first raids here for battle for
Azeroth was released method made a
shocking announcement
it wasn't the first time ever that raid
progression had been live stream but it
was the first time that a guild with as
much on the line as a message had done
it
I mean we've actually talked about
streaming baiting you know the way
progress for many years actually to be
honest the method just thought it was
always met with quite a lot of
opposition I guess you could say from
the guild itself in the past there's a
very good reason not to livestream raids
top guilds don't want the strategies
they used to defeat bosses falling into
their rivals hands
some people even tried to sabotage their
rival guilds though they were quickly to
sound
there was one drawback to method stream
though in order to maintain their
advantage you couldn't hear their voice
comms so the stream was risky and
somewhat incomplete but there was a
bigger question who cared method may
have been the favourites to win the
world first race but the Warcraft was
nearly 14 years old and it was never
really popular on twitch outside of
expansion releases but the race didn't
disappoint as viewers were treated to an
epic finish after the first week of
mythic guilds working on the final boss
of old dear Cahoon like method and their
n a counterpart limit we're faced with a
choice raids in a while reset every week
but your progress can be extended to the
next week which means that you re-enter
the raid instance at the same Falls but
it also means that you can't kill all
the bosses again and get some
potentially much-needed aleut after
getting the hune to under 1% HP in week
1 limit decided to extend their lockout
for going another week of loot to start
immediately at Cahoon method decided to
reset guessing that the extra loot would
be enough to push them over the top in
the end method stood triumphant over go
home even with the stream and the you
disadvantaged but the viewer response
was even more shocking than the finale
over the course of the race methods
channels peaked over 250,000 viewers
guild leader and main tank scots go
McMillan's channel broke 150,000 when
they finally killed you home the
official method channel treated the
event more like an eSport even adding
commentary from various observers while
pulling everybody together again I can't
emphasize enough how much the add
control is integral the importance of
the moment is up for debate but interest
in the race isn't the method stream
proved more popular than some official
Blizzard eSports events so is there
eSports potential here just waiting to
be harnessed maybe but it probably looks
less like League of Legends and more
like say speedrunning there isn't new
raid content Wow every day in fact raves
only come out about three times a year
but maybe there's potential for an event
like games done quick something that can
draw in viewership are on a new raid
while dedicated community can stick with
it me around
in any case hardcore Raiders and yields
like method often use vacation time in
order to raid 14 hours a day like they
need to for the race so it's not
something that could do every week but
what method livestream did accomplish
without question is show that there's
still an audience on Twitch for watching
the best while players compete at the
highest level thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]